great your daddy dude what is he to
friction play guns computer I don't hope
I don't know actually he does effects
like sparkles cutsies sits egg
computing does stuff I'm a Senior
Programmer I'm a UI program
I'm a senior designer my mom's an artist
she works pretty hard
I am a klutz designer I'm a senior
character artist yeah definitely is a
very familiar environment my dad makes
video games play mommy
spay okay I always wanted to make games
I dreamt of this kind of job when I was
a kid I grew up loving games when he was
little this was actually his dream job
it never occurred to me that it could be
a job sometimes I still feel like that
kid me I'm an adult sometimes I have to
pinch myself that it's real I love what
I do
I mean it's video games for a living
that's got to be really cool
of course my dad's games made people
feel happy scared excited badass I'll
kind of Skilling's I'm actually working
on an RPG I'm working on a shooter oh
it's a really cool mobile game eSports
first person third person fantasy
dystopian a higher game it'll scare the
[ __ ] out of you and finally something
everyone our games really exciting
awesome scary overwhelming mind-blowing
I'm really proud of my dad my mom works
hard and now they're ready they made
their game and this is it it's go John
time to show everyone what we've been
working except me I can't play till I'm
older awesome
let's get it started are you ready Oh
so let's just say it starts this Joe
start to sell shoe toys I don't know if
you're Chinese welcome welcome to the
heat release your gaze
[Music]
[Music]
I'd hate for the pain
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
welcome everyone to bethesda land 2017
yes bethesda land a place of adventure
innovation wonderment but above all else
fun
to get things started please welcome
Bethesda's global vice-president of PR
and marketing Pete Hines
[Applause]
thank you very much I can't even imagine
the size of the bar tab that it paid it
for that applause but I thank you for
that good evening and welcome to the
2017 Bethesda III showcase and welcome
to Bethesda Lane we will offer you an
experience at e3 unlike anything else
and a chance to celebrate some of the
world's best video games tonight we'll
be taking you on a virtual tour through
our playground where there's something
for everyone whether it's phone or
tablet PC or your favorite Xbox
Playstation or tendo console or like
many of us all of the above but before
we turn to the latest from Bethesda
let's take a minute to look at the some
of the most recent games that you've
been playing and many of you are still
enjoying like the endless hours of fun
that millions of fans have had playing
Doom ripping tearing and otherwise
eviscerating demons from hell
did you play a badass supernatural
assassin in Dishonored 2 or fight to
survive aboard an alien festive Space
Station in prey maybe you're one of the
100 million people around the world who
have enjoyed building and overseeing
your own vault in fallout shelter and I
know that many of you are still playing
fallout 4 and Skyrim special edition
probably because for the first time in
our industry both games offer user mods
for console players with more than 300
million mod downloads since we launched
them last year as each of these
extraordinary games show Bethesda works
hard for you giving players the very
best entertainment experience regardless
of your taste platform or playstyle
so what's next let's start by talking
about virtual reality something that
we've been at the forefront of for a
while now we've had teams hard at work
on VR titles to provide the kind of
experiences you've been asking for and
the kind of experience you won't find
anywhere else so let's start our tour of
Bethesda land with two VR games coming
out this year you ready let's take a
look
welcome to the UAC
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
turn on your magic
[Music]
this
[Music]
[Music]
finally a full-length open-world game
with near limitless content playable
entirely in VR sure will be exciting to
play fallout 4 in VR plus Doom VFR it's
so hot right now
[Music]
expansive open worlds and endless player
choice are two of the cornerstone on
which bethesda was built the Elder
Scrolls online first released in 2014
and has built a massive community since
launch more than 10 million players have
had countless adventures in Tamriel now
you can return to a thrilling fan
favorite location Mora when what's up
guys it's out it's Jean Jamie gonna be
exciting I'm pretty excited right now
here we go Omega Luke collection racing
right now
[Music]
Lucian arrows into that bear they're not
fair
nice shield or you can
that was amazing I can't wait
[Music]
everybody has said this is what we've
been won
Elder Scrolls online made me feel like I
was 14 again
I gotta watch the bear again real quick
get us on a bear
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
speaking of Morrowind did you know that
Bethesda's first PC user mods in 2002
were for the Elder Scrolls 3 morrowind
15 years later but as des continues to
support the mod community last year
bethesda user mods were made available
to Xbox one and PlayStation 4 players
and since then there have been more than
300 million mod downloads for Fallout 4
and Skyrim special edition and we're
just getting started in 2017
Bethesda is going to shake things up
again bethesda game studios is known for
creating open living worlds with
seemingly limitless gameplay content but
what if there was another way to
experience even more something all-new
introducing creation club a collection
of new game content for Skyrim and
fallout 4 including new weapons new
armor new outfits and accessories new
crafting and housing features even new
gameplay enhancements using creation
Club is easy browse the selection
in-game by category and use credits to
download right there your new content
will appear automatically creation club
content is made by Bethesda Game Studios
and outside developers including the
very best community creators these
outside creators work hand-in-hand with
Bethesda Game Studios which means all
content will be fully compatible with
your save games achievements and
official add-ons creation Club is coming
this summer for the PlayStation 4 Xbox
one and PC creation Club the worlds of
Fallout 4 and Skyrim just got a little
bit bigger
[Music]
the elderscrolls legends is another way
to explore this amazing universe taking
you beyond the role-playing experience
and offering a unique strategy card game
but we haven't shown all our cards yet
let's see what snacks for legends
[Music]
stories can do surprising things whether
they are true or not and this is one you
should hear
the warrior strength and courage
[Music]
I have you now
[Music]
even those lost amongst the mountains
can find their way within the stars
the path is written for you to find
the path to warriors destined for
sovngarde
two beasts cursed by an unquenchable
hunger
two scholars of ancient and ferocious
magic
terrors from above
they all await in Skyrim
you must simply find the path
[Music]
the elderscrolls has given tens of
millions of fans just like you the
chance to live another life in another
world now for the first time
Skyrim one of our most beloved games is
coming to a Nintendo platform now that's
a switch
[Music]
Oh
[Music]
tomorrow Sun buildings green sky
[Music]
well
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
bethesda has always believed in
immersive worlds in which players can
tell their own stories be who they want
to be and do what they want to do this
September get ready for another
adventure in the Dishonored universe a
story of revenge and the ultimate
assassination
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
now it's good to see you old man
you up for one last job Billy who's the
mark the black eyed bastard responsible
for all the chaos we're gonna kill the
outsider
[Music]
in 1996 its software offered gamers a
new exciting way to play and compete
that year marked the true birth of
eSports and it began with the land party
in Dallas Texas fans came together to
play a fast-paced revolutionary new
shooter called quake it offered them a
new way to compete and the best of the
best were finally recognized as
professional gamers this year quake
champions takes eSports to the next
level
[Music]
we weren't born champions were made
made better
made faster
[Music]
made deadlier with every single match
we don't just play we compete
we achieve
we rise
we won't stop until we're the best
until we are quick champions
coming at you
Oh
[Music]
[Applause]
juice it up baby
what's the matter lose something you'll
regret that
cheers on
try to keep up
Oh who's next
you've done messed up now
I'm coming for you goddamn weirdos
you win it all comes down to this every
match every frag every victory more than
20 years in the making
the original eSport returns
announcing the quake World Championships
August 26th at QuakeCon in Dallas Texas
competitors will face off in the
ultimate eSports arena to win their
share of 1 million dollars and the one
thing every champion seeks
legacy
play the beta now and get ready for the
quake World Championships physique wacom
to learn more you might notice some
parts of Bethesda Lane have been under
construction but now the work is nearly
finished let's take a peek sebastien for
three years since beacon happened you've
been searching for answers you didn't
find what you're looking for because
they didn't want you to mobius knows
you've been following us they've been
watching you for a long time you trained
and trusted me and in return I betrayed
you long before he met he lost her
daughter Lily she's still alive
this is your chance to save her to get
back what you lost Lily needs you you're
gonna need to go back into stem again
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
today
[Music]
to
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
Hey
crazy
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
Wow on Friday October 13th the evil
within - will surely be giving us all
nightmares
[Music]
we hope you've enjoyed your time in
Bethesda lab and as we near the end of
our tour we leave you with one more
coming attraction here you go Peggy as
everything your mother ordered and a
ration card and here's a locker each
Necker just for you
Wow gee thanks mr. Walton
[Music]
I'm gonna get you out get it on leave
okay good girl
[Music]
[Music]
Oh bad girl
the nutrition is a matter of state
security wunderbar soldier who ever
lived
[Applause]
welcome back to round three now is very
it's really exciting on America's number
one game show okay hands on your buzzers
here we go
the Honorable you exercise self-control
all the joy and pain Picture Show
second balcony
was the place with meat second seat go
Dutch treat you were sweet
the old and the wait are doomed William
I prayed for you to wake up
we've gotten so fat that says we're
having twins uh fro England she's been
hunting for you she's been moving heaven
and earth and today she found you you
think your hero William Joseph flask
foster's did this monsters
hello
come on Peter let's go someplace else
mom no nuts
oh btw sure duck you one strawberry
milkshake please oh I hope you don't
have a fire back there to put out if so
I'll come back another time
I'm sure the fire can wait coming done
one strawberry milkshake coming right up
fireman I recognize your face very Aryan
face it is - are you out of station one
day you're coming up Oh
vielen dank mmm
now you show me your identification
papers please
we got the fighting spirit back in the
American people
so contracts expire
[Music]
just who the [ __ ] you write boy stay
calm
let me first make it absolutely clear
that I am NOT a Nazi were you saying say
your Nazi I'll [ __ ] this [ __ ]
let me say this again I ain't no goddamn
Nazi huh now you bring superfish back in
and you put him down right now
I will shell this grenade so far up your
ass hey uh I got precious little time
for your [ __ ] we've been trying to
make contact with your group we're
organizing for a revolution in America
we pick our legs it's just a dead oh
there's gonna say for the longest time
I've been hearing through the grapevine
about this resistance
leader
porty you know my mall we said never
trust a man can't handle his whiskey so
you sit right down
say terror billion drink up now listen
Tara Billy
I respect your ambition but there's
nothing gonna be done no more the world
was sank into the crapper and all we can
do now is drink this whiskey watch the
ball take suck it all down didn't expect
your belly to be quite so yellow we
stood up against the imperialist war
machine in the United States of America
and the greedy money minute Wall Street
you was gonna send the children of the
proletariat off to dive foreign lands so
that they could be filling their coffers
it worked their sons bleeding on the
beaches I got kids on the way and I'll
be damned if I'm gonna raise them in a
world run by these not yet
you take freedom away from the American
people you're playing with fire can I
attend pour some gasoline
[Music]
[Music]
stay
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
nah
[Music]
I said a couple of months ago that the
thing that machinegames was working on
is [ __ ] bananas so now you know what
I mean by [ __ ] bananas a lady
pregnant with twins stabbing and Nazi
while a guy's dropping acid is [ __ ]
bananas
we can't wait to more show to show you
guys more of Wolfenstein 2 and how it
combines two compelling shooter with
great story unforgettable characters and
killer graphics with over-the-top action
so if you visit our booth this week at
e3 you have a chance to go hands-on and
begin the fight to rally the resistance
in America against the Nazi regime in
addition to Wolfenstein - we'll have
hands-on for our VR titles so you can
play both fallout 4 and doom VFR you can
play great champions and start
practicing for that big million dollar
prize pool at QuakeCon or you can try
the battlegrounds mode in the new Elder
Scrolls online morwen plus we have
hands-on for the new heroes of Skyrim
for legends plus a cool interactive
experience for the evil within two
exclusive develop interviews
presentations and a lot more so we hope
you're as excited for what we have
coming in 2017 as we are again a
reminder everything that you saw tonight
be out this year be it mobile or PC
console or virtual reality shooter
horror RPG action or strategy card game
we believe Bethesda will remain the
place to go for the very best in video
games we hope you've enjoyed this
evening showcase it's your passion and
excitement that drives our teams to make
something great something exciting
something fun if you're here at e3 we
hope you'll come by the booth and say hi
if you're not here in LA please keep
doing Bethesda sunette well we'll have
lots more to say about the games you saw
tonight in the coming days weeks and
months and we thank all of you online
for joining us please have a good night
[Applause]